air Travelers have had plenty to
complain about in recent weeks the
issues range from the Southwest Airlines
meltdown over the holidays to an FAA
computer glitch that led to a Nationwide
ground stop just last week flight
attendants are among the industry's
front-line workers when these
disruptions happen Janet shamlin takes
us behind the scenes of their training
to find out how it's evolving to meet
new and old challenges
[Music]
another day it's preparation they'll
likely never have to use
but this is part of the rigorous
schooling all future United flight
attendants go through at the airline's
newly opened 56 000 square foot training
center in Houston
it's six weeks of instruction drills and
testing the airline aims to hire 4 000
flight attendants this year the training
reinforced as often as once a year this
is our door training room Michelle
Siegel Johnson is United's vice
president of in-flight Services you have
a lot of positions to fill yes how tough
is that it's evident by how many people
still want to be a flight attendant I
mean 69 000 applications over a year
hiring less than six percent the
pandemic saw thousands of flight
attendants who either quit or furloughed
or took a buyout then his travel
rebounded Airlines were short staffed
and all are now hiring trainees like 57
year old Carl Gilbert kind of old but
then I thought this would be a nice
career transition to take me into
retirement and
cut firefighter do you think this would
be less stressful not at all
no are you gonna be a firefighter you're
going to be a health care responder you
get to be in customer service and you
get to travel the world but first
there's this
way the mechanics of opening the doors
of six different aircraft types a rare
situation where a flight attendant would
need to do this but in the event we're
ready
a model of a plane's fuselage in the new
Aquatic Center
has trainees practicing for water
landing and there's the everyday duties
of food and beverage service in what
looks like a wide-bodied plain it's not
just service and safety a big part of
training focuses on de-escalation
techniques a sign of the times with a
pandemic trend of unruly passengers
there's emphasis on how to react it's
not what we say but it's how we say it
and it's the way that we approach that
situation excuse me teams run through
potential scenarios but why are we on I
don't understand
I apologize I sincerely apologize we put
them in scenarios where they have to
respond in a way they can be empathetic
and informative the median pay for
flight attendants Nationwide is just
under 62 000 a year new hires earn less
but attracted to the perks of travel
trainees like Kylie streck taking the
plunge how does that compare to
firefighting man it was a rush it was a
nice little rush elevating training for
the changing challenges of ensuring
safety in the skies for CBS mornings I'm
Janet shamlian in Houston
uh just another example the great work
that flight attendants do they're not
there just to serve you you know your
food or to tell you to do your seatbelt
they really are there for you and by the
way it's clearly quite an elite core
people yeah you've got tens of thousands
of applicants only six percent get
accepted uh the training for the unruly
passages though it's interesting Nate no
doubt about it I used to believe with
how film and TV depicted flight
attendants it was this glamorous job you
know you just handed out drinks and you
traveled all over the world not true but
the way that people travel now and the
Knuckleheads we see on these fights it's
a tough game the way people behave it
really is the escalation they call it
you got to be good at it